-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night."
And now if you don't mind,
everybody,
we're going to get to the news.
Republican leader Kevin McCarthy
over the weekend
was elected the 55th Speaker
of the House of Representatives.
And when I say over the weekend,
I mean over the...
[ Laughter ]
It took 15 rounds of voting
before McCarthy
finally secured the position.
They chose McCarthy the same way
you'd choose Thai food
on New Year's Day.
"You guys want Thai?
Well, nothing else is open."
[ Laughter ]
Ahead of the last round
of voting for House Speaker,
Alabama Congressman Mike Rogers
appeared to charge
at fellow Republican
Representative Matt Gaetz,
and, out of habit, Gaetz yelled,
"I've never even met
your daughter!"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden
traveled yesterday
to the U.S./Mexico border
and was met at the airport
by Texas Governor Greg Abbott,
'cause if there's one way
to show someone you hate them,
it's to make them
pick you up at the airport.
[ Laughter ]
After spending time
with his family
in the U.S. Virgin Islands
over the holidays,
President Biden is reportedly
planning to announce
he will run for reelection
because nothing reminds you
how much you love your job
like some holiday time
with the family.
[ Laughter ]
In a post on Truth Social
over the weekend,
former President Trump said
that he helped
House Speaker Kevin McCarthy
get elected.
Dude, he lost 14 times in a row.
[ Laughter ]
That's --
It's just not a great brag.
That's like saying
you helped
get Jurassic Park reopened.
All right.
But, like, we can't consider
that a success.
Russian President Vladimir Putin
on Friday
attended a Christmas Eve mass
at a Russian Orthodox Church
alone.
It happens to the best of us.
You know, one day you look
around and realize
that all your friends
have been pushed out a window.
[ Laughter ]
[ Laughter
and scattered applause ]
And you'll have
a merry Christmas, anyway.
A new law is set
to take event in -- Sorry.
A new law is set to take effect
in Connecticut tomorrow
that allows the sale
of recreational cannabis
where it will be smoked
by the only people
who actually call it cannabis.
"Ooh!"
[ Laughter ]
"James, a cannabis cigarette."
"Do we dare?"
[ Laughter ]
By the way, fair warning to
anyone who plans on partaking.
Don't think too hard
about the word "Connecticut."
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter continues ]
Connect-icut?
[ Light laughter ]
A group of whale watchers
off the coast of California
recently saw a gray whale
give birth to a calf
right next to their boat,
and then again whenever they
close their eyes from now on.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, Delta Air Lines
announced last week
that, next month, it will begin
offering customers free Wi-Fi.
Meanwhile, Spirit is offering
to show customers
how to write "BOOBS"
on a calculator.
[ Laughter ]
And that...
[ Cheers and applause ]
...was the monologue, everybody.
We've got a great show
for you tonight.